In light of the fact that I have just sent you paper topics.
My lecture today is going to do two things.
It is going to give you a way into Franny and Zooey but it's going to actually
give you more than a way into it.
It's really going to give you a whole packaged reading of Frannie and slowly we
have just the one day on this novel
and what I'm going to be doing for you is modeling the way literary critics use
evidence to advance an argument.
It's useful to you when you think about writing a paper to remember if it's been
a long time since you've written an English paper or even if it isn't a long
time since you've written an English paper that the facts that we literary
critics and you writers on literature,
the fact that we deal with are the details of the text itself.
You may have noticed that I am very fond of reading aloud to you from these
novels.
I'm very fond of reading out passages.
I do it a lot.
Why do I do it?
Well,
there are two reasons.
One because I want you to hear literary art.
Literary art is a verbal art.
And I think too often we only read it silently,
probably not since you were children that people read to you so much.
So to get a sense of that,
you have to have it in your ear and feel the sound and the rhythm and the
quality,
the Tambour,
the expression of the voices that we have in these novels are writer for today,
thinks so highly of that capacity of literature to embody the human voice that
he imagines a whole religious world around it.
That's going to be the gist of my argument today.
But then there's a second sort of less,
uh,
Mr. Cole reason and that's that these are the facts of a literary argument.
These words that I give to you,
it's like if you are in an astronomy lecture,
they're going to give you some facts about the composition of a planet or its
atmosphere or whatever.
Those are the facts for that field,
for this field.
These are the facts.
So in your papers,
if you find yourself writing and you get to the end of a page and you look back,
you scan back over your page and you see that there are no quotation marks,
you are not using any of the facts of the novel to produce your argument to
support your claims.
So that's like the eye test,
the glance test.
Are you supporting your claims?
If you have very few quotations,
chances are you are not.
So think of this lecture as I go through it as a kind of model,
pay attention to what I'm doing in using these textual bits and pieces and
putting them together and making claims for them.
I do it every week.
Um,
it just so happens that this argument is more closed,
more settled in my own mind.
It's less of an opening argument than it is something that I want to convince
you of.
So there's a,
there's a reason for that.
Um,
and that is that I'm writing about this novel.
It's in the introduction to a book that I'm writing about the literature of this
period.
And so it's very present to my mind as a sort of piece of a larger argument
about religion and the American novel in this period.
Um,
so that's what I'm giving you.
When you approach any novel to make an argument about it.
If you want to be ambitious,
the first thing to think about is,
well,
what's obvious about the novel?
What can you observe at first glance about it's style,
about its form,
about setting,
about its character,
about its presuppositions in Franny and Zooey.
What did you notice?
Tell me what you noticed at first bat,
if any of you have read it.
What did you notice about the novel
doesn't move around,
stays in one place.
Absolutely.
Confined settings.
Very confined settings.
Absolutely.
Yes.
What else?
Lots of dialogue.
Yes.
What else?
[inaudible]
very much in the living room.
Yeah.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah.
There's a backstory.
You can feel that backstory to the novel.
Yeah.
What else?
What else did you notice?
Yes,
that's a lot of focus on like little motions that people do like yeah.
Cigarettes and dropping things.
Yeah,
a lot of attention to physical detail and physical movement.
And that's connected to this point about confined spaces.
It's the movement of bodies within confined spaces that really preoccupies this
novel.
What about the style of the novel?
Talk about dialogue.
Is there anything else about the style that you noticed?
Yes.
One of Italics.
What does that connote to you?
MMM.
[inaudible]
yeah,
absolutely.
A lot of emphasis,
a lot of variation in tone in the Italics are part of the representation of
that.
Yeah.
What else?
Yes.
A lot of the dialogue seems to be [inaudible].
This is a book about arguments.
Absolutely.
What are they arguing about
most of the time?
All right,
well that's where I will pick up.
Oh,
Sarah,
do you want to say adds jobs,
things intellectual?
Yeah.
Yeah,
absolutely.
They're,
they're talking about abstract,
intellectual ideas,
often religious or philosophical ones.
Um,
and that plus it's setting,
I hope you notice the sort of new haven ish setting of Franny's breakdown where
we're told that a lean isn't exactly a Yale man,
but he sure looks a lot like a Yale,
Yale,
English major.
Um,
dare I say such an unpleasant character.
and so,
so pompous.
What you do when you write a paper or try to advance an argument.
It's try to write an argument that will attend to all those things that you guys
just said,
that you take the obvious things.
And when you craft an argument,
the best thing,
the most ambitious thing to do is to come up with something where in the end you
can say something about those major aspects.
You don't have to do it in the paper,
but it should be an argument that has something to say back to those obvious
things.
Why is the style this way?
Why is the plot working this way?
Why are these particular characters behaving in this way?
Why use those confined spaces?
So my argument today is going to try to have something to say back to all those
obvious aspects that you pointed out.
Um,
so rightly,
but I'm going to start from a much more pointed and local question.
And this is the other thing that a good short paper especially does is that you
don't get it all that big stuff by kind of taking it head on,
you have to come down to the facts that I was talking about.
The bits of text,
the text itself,
the words that author chose,
that's where you begin.
And part of the genius of a strong paper is choosing the place in the text to
begin that pointed analysis.
So my choice for this is that odd introduction in between the two stories,
and this is on 48 and 49
this is,
we come to find out buddy Zoe's older brother narrating the story and buddy
gives us a little preamble telling us how the real characters in the story,
the real people who are van characters in his story,
how they felt about the story and what their objections to at were.
And this is on 48
we find out that Franny objects to the stories distribution in the world or the
movie,
the pros home movie as buddy calls it.
Uh,
because it shows her blowing her nose a lot.
Okay.
His mother Bessie objects because it shows her in her house coat,
but Zoe has a more substantive objection.
It's the leading man.
However,
who has made the most eloquent appeal to me to call off the production.
This is in the middle of page 48 he feels that the plot hinges on mysticism or
religious mystification in any case,
he makes it very clear,
a to vividly apparent transcendent element of sorts,
which he says he's worried can only expedite,
move up the day and hour of my professional undoing.
People are already shaking their heads over me and any immediate further
professional use on my part of the word God,
except as a familiar healthy American expletive will be taken or rather
confirmed as the very worst kind of name dropping and a sure sign that I'm going
straight to the dogs
and he speaks back to Zoe.
He says,
well,
I'm going to still distribute my story.
I still want to tell this story.
And he does it in a kind of roundabout way,
and this is on on page 49
okay.
Somewhere in the great Gatsby,
which was my Tom Sawyer when I was 12 the youthful narrator remarks that
everybody's suspect himself of having at least one of the cardinal virtues and
he goes on to say that he thinks his,
bless his heart.
His honesty,
mine,
I think is that I know the difference between a mystical story and a love story.
I say that my current offering isn't a mystical story or a religiously
mystifying story at all.
I say it's a compound or multiple love story.
Pure and complicated.
Yeah.
What buddy does in this passage is set up this opposition between his own
reading of his story and Zoe's.
Now,
why are we given these objections?
I think it's to give us a dynamic sense of the family conversation going on
between them,
but it also addresses one of those obvious things.
They talk a lot,
as Sarah said,
they talk a lot about abstract questions and this puts the meaning of the story
in that abstract register.
Is it a love story or is it a religious story?
A mystifying story,
which is it?
I am going to argue that it's both and I'm going to advance that argument by
going straight to the theological question that Zoe is so intent on solving when
Franny is having her breakdown in the living room.
Yeah.
So just to,
uh,
review Franny has her breakdown when she comes into what I suspect is new haven
to attend the Yale Harvard game football game with her boyfriend lane.
So
yeah.
Frannie when she sees lane affects great enthusiasm and so on.
But this is what we hear about lane from the narrator.
This is on page 11
lane was speaking now as someone who does,
who has been monopolizing the conversation for a good quarter of an hour or so,
and who believes he has just hit a stride where his voice can do absolutely no
wrong.
You know,
I always read this and I think I'm lecturing.
It's all good.
I mean to put it crudely,
he's,
he was saying,
the thing you could say he lacks is testicular parity.
You know what I mean?
He was slouched rhetorically forward toward Franny is receptive audience,
uh,
supporting forearm on either side of his Martini.
Lacks what Franny said.
She'd had to clear her throat before speaking.
It had been so long since she had said anything at all.
Laying hesitated masculinity.
He said,
I heard you the first time.
Anyway,
it was one of,
it was the Motif of the thing,
so to speak.
What I was trying to bring out in a fairly subtle way.
Lane said very closely following the trend of his own conversation.
I mean,
God,
I honestly thought I was,
it was going to go over like a goddamn led balloon and when I got it back with
this goddamn a on it in letters about six feet high,
I swear I nearly keeled over Frannie again,
cleared her throat.
Apparently herself imposed sentence of unadulterated good listenership had been
fully served.
Why?
She asked lane looked faintly interrupted.
Why,
what,
why do you think it was going to go over like a lead balloon?
I just told you,
I just got through saying this guy,
uh,
brome is a big flow bear man or at least I thought he was.
Oh,
Franny said she smiled.
Franny is disgusted by his pomposity.
Yeah.
This experience combined with her experience in a religion seminar with this
man,
Professor Tupper at school has convinced herself that the world is superficial,
that it's impossible to find anything meaningful in the academic discussion of
these pseudo intellectual problems.
The test secularity of one writer or another.
Okay.
And lanes engagement with literature specifically is all about his ego
inflation.
So he can't wait to tell Franny that the professor said he should try to publish
it.
And then my favorite thing,
he wants to read it to her over the football weekend.
Hey,
come,
let's read my English Essay.
Hello?
Uh,
no you can't.
Sorry.
And I'm worried about email
talking about pricking my pomposity.
Um,
all right,
so,
so she starts saying the Jesus prayer,
which is Lord Jesus Christ,
son of God,
have mercy on me,
a sinner.
Now she has taken this prayer from a book called the way of the pilgrim.
It's a Russian Orthodox religious classic,
very old text.
And it depicts the life of a pilgrim.
And we get the summary of this a little bit in the novel as Frannie explains it
or tries to explain it to lane who's entirely uninterested.
Um,
it is about a man who tries to take seriously the bibles in junction to pray
without ceasing.
And the prayer for Franny becomes a kind of mantra.
She's trying to say it over and over again as she goes about in this world that
is so disappointing to her feel so false to her.
And so finally,
the strain of trying to hold out this kind of religious awareness in the face of
lane and his English paper is just too much and she faints.
Now,
Zoe has a big problem with her use of this prayer and this is what gives the
book that sort of combative tone,
um,
that we,
uh,
that we were talking about a little earlier that somebody mentioned.
So if you look on page one 69,
my question now is in my argument,
what is Zoe's critique of Franny's use of the prayer?
What,
what constitutes that critique?
What's wrong with it?
Yeah.
So in one 69,
he says to Franny as she's snuggling on the couch,
God Almighty,
he said,
if you're going to say the Jesus prayer,
at least say it to Jesus and not to Saint Francis and Seymour and Heidi's
grandfather all wrapped up in one.
Keep him in mind if you say it and him only and him has,
he was and not as you'd like him to have been.
You don't face any facts.
This same damn data tude of not facing facts is what got you into this messy
state of mind in the first place and it can't possibly get you out of it.
And then this,
this,
um,
this argument goes on for a couple of pages and I'm just going to pick up the
end of it here on the bottom of one 71,
he's,
he's explaining who Jesus was.
If you don't understand Jesus,
you can't understand his prayer.
You don't get the prayer at all.
You just get some kind of organized can't.
Jesus was a supreme adept by God on a terribly important mission.
This was no seat.
Francis with enough time to knock out a few canticles or to preach to the birds
or do any of the other endearing things.
So close to Frannie glosses heart.
I'm being serious now.
God dammit.
How can you miss seeing that if God had wanted somebody with Saint Francis is
consistently winning personality for the job in the new testament heat have
picked him.
You can be sure as it was,
he picked the best,
the smartest,
the most loving,
the least sentimental,
the most an imitative master he could have possibly picked.
And when you miss seeing that,
I swear to you,
you're missing the whole point of the Jesus prayer.
Yeah.
So Zoe's critique is that Franny is not being specific in her use of the prayer.
She's paying no attention to who Jesus was and what it means to actually pray to
that figure.
Yeah.
But to anyone paying attention to the other things that Zoe says and the other
things that he does in this novel,
this is kind of odd and it's hard to square.
So my next kind of question is how does that vary?
Doc tribally specific understanding of the Jesus prayer relate to the whole
religious education that buddy and Seymour gave him and that he seems to be
thinking so hard about as he reads that letter in the bathtub.
Yeah.
The letter in the bathtub tells us about that education and let's look on 61
yeah,
sorry.
I want to,
that's not exactly the right page.
This is 65 I'm sorry.
Yeah.
In this buddy explains
to Zoe what he and Seymour had been trying to do.
Much,
much more important though.
Buddy says in the middle of 65 Seymour had already begun to believe and I agreed
with him as far as able,
as I was able to see the point that education by any name would smell as sweet
and maybe much sweeter if it didn't begin with a quest for knowledge at all.
But with a quest as zen would put it for no knowledge.
Doctor Suzuki says somewhere that to be in a state of pure consciousness,
Satori is to be with God.
Before he said,
let there be light.
Seymour.
And I thought it might be a good thing to hold back this light from you and
Franny,
at least as far as we are able and all the many lower,
more fashionable lighting effects,
the arts,
sciences,
classics,
languages,
till you were both able,
at least to conceive of a state of being where the mind knows the source of all
light.
So the religious education that Zoe's response to Frannie comes out of is
precisely not a doc triangley specific Christian education.
Rather,
it's something more like a Buddhist tradition,
a syncretic mystical tradition.
The idea is that there is some state of being with God,
knowledge,
all the arts and sciences,
literature,
all the religious writings of the world are manifestations of that voice that at
its origin is God's saying,
let there be light.
It's the voice of creation.
Seymour and buddy want Franny and Zooey to rest at that origin undistracted by
the manifestations of the creation and know some kind of consciousness of God in
that place.
So Zoe pretty much subscribes to these,
these tenants,
and you can see it,
especially on page one 75
okay.
When he goes into his brother's old room.
Now let me explain a detail that I think is important,
but I think a little lost to us in today's world of technology,
there's a phone and buddy and Seymour old room that is a PR,
a private internal line and it just goes from one room to another in the
apartment.
It's not an outside phone line.
And what's interesting about it and what,
um,
indicates importance to buddy is that Betsy gets on about him getting a phone
where he's teaching,
uh,
in upstate New York.
He's teaching writing as a visiting writer at a college in upstate New York.
And,
and Bessie,
his mother keeps saying,
well,
why don't,
why won't you get a phone buddy?
You're,
you're paying to maintain this interior align in our apartment and yet you won't
get a phone for buddy.
The phone that's within the family compound,
so to speak,
family apartment is the more important line of communication.
So when Zoe goes upstairs to use that phone,
it's freighted with all the significance that buddy has put upon it.
But there's a whole ritual involved.
Yeah.
In Zoe's entrance into this place.
Okay.
This is on one 75
yeah.
At the far end of the hall,
he went into the bedroom.
He had once shared with his twin brothers,
which now in 1955 was his alone,
but he stayed in his room for not more than two minutes.
When he came out,
he had on the same sweaty shirt.
There was however a slight but fairly distinct change in his appearance.
He had acquired a cigar and lighted it and for some reason he had unfolded,
unfolded white handkerchief draped over his head,
possibly to ward off rain or hail or brimstone.
So why does he do this?
What's the meaning of this little,
the tale of Zoe's appearance?
Well,
one thing that a literary argument can do is take something small like this and
try to give an account for it.
So that's what I'm going to do.
He's venerating the state,
the room that Seymour and buddy occupied.
He's covering his head in a traditional religious fashion.
So in order to enter this holy place,
he covers his head,
the cigar.
I don't have an account of that.
You guys figured that out?
Yeah.
That's the other nice thing about literary arguments.
There are always little details that they don't account for.
And that's the,
the loose thread that you can pull to make your own.
Yeah.
And so what does he find when he goes into this holy space?
Well,
he finds two panels of
beaver board on one 78,
179.
And they have the quotations that Seymour in buddy have collected from all their
favorite religious,
philosophical,
mystical literary reading.
And I'd like you just to,
uh,
think about one of them.
So this is the bottom of one 78.
This is from Sri Ramakrishna.
Sir,
we ought to teach the people that they are doing wrong in worshiping the images
and pictures in the temple.
Rama,
Krishna,
that's the way with you Calcutta people you want to teach and preach.
You want to give millions when you are beggars yourselves.
Do you think God does not know that he is being worshiped in the images and
pictures?
If a worshiper should make a mistake,
do you not think God will know his intent?
This is,
I think,
one of the best examples of that syncretic view of religion,
that basically all worshipers are worshiping the same God.
They may do it in different forms,
they may make mistakes,
they may be mistaken about where God resides,
but in this view,
God is so powerful and so transcendent that God will know the heart of the
worshiper.
So if you apply that back to Frannie,
why,
why does Zoe have this difficulty?
Why does he have this difficulty in the specificity of her prayer?
What is it that is bothering her,
him?
Well,
I think you begin to get an answer to this tension between specific doctrine and
syncretic religion.
When Zoe gets to the subject of acting,
which is what this second attempt at speaking to Frannie this time over the
phone is,
uh,
concerned with,
there's a detail here of course,
that Zoe and making a second attempt to converse with Frannie about this
impersonates his brother buddy on the phone.
Now I'm just going to leave that observation,
remind you of that.
I have a way to account for that,
but it's gonna take to the end of my argument to do that.
So I'm going to argue that that's significant,
but I'm not going to talk about why it's significant yet.
But let's look at that theology of acting.
This is on page one 98
this is coming towards the climax of their conversation.
Part of what's been bothering Franny is her frustration with acting and that's
one of the things that lane is so surprised she has given up.
It was the only thing she was passionate about.
And we know from reading buddies letter over Zoe's shoulder in the bathtub.
We know that Zoe had concerns about his own acting career,
his own commitment to acting
that buddy tried to persuade him out of.
You can say the Jesus Prayer Zoe says to Franny from now until doomsday,
but if you don't realize that the only thing that counts in the religious life
is detachment.
I don't see how you'll ever even move an inch detachment buddy and only
detachment desire less snus cessation from all hankering.
It's this business of desiring.
If you want to know the God damn truth that makes an actor in the first place or
are you making me tell you things you already know?
Somewhere along the line in one damn incarnation or another,
if you like,
you not only had a hankering to be an actor or an actress,
but to be a good one,
you're stuck with it now.
You can't just walk out on the results of your own hankerings cause and effect
buddy cause and effect.
The only thing you can do now,
the only religious thing you can do is act,
act for God.
If you want to be gods actress,
if you want to,
what could be prettier?
Zoe has this understanding of the cosmos that suggests that strong specific
human desires actually changed the course of cosmic futures.
So somewhere,
maybe in pre incarnational time before Franny became Franny,
she wanted to be an actress.
The religious things always says is to inhabit that,
to honor that,
to follow up on the results of that prior desiring,
but why is it acting?
Why specifically acting and why this weird comment at the end,
what could be prettier?
What does prettiness have to do with this?
Well,
if you look at the description for instance of Zoe's face,
there's a beautiful description of how his face is beautiful in what way?
His face is beautiful.
We know that Franny is,
is an attractive young woman.
We know that she worries about beauty and especially in poetry when she's trying
to explain what's wrong.
Part of what's wrong is that when she learns poetry in the classroom,
none of it seems beautiful to her.
It all seems like some other kind of production,
not the production of beauty.
Okay,
so prettiness beauty.
The aesthetic
is at the heart of the spiritual practice that Zoe is urging upon Franny,
the spiritual practice of acting.
And I would remind you,
looking back to that passage on page 65 and into the 66 that specifically among
the figures that buddy mentions,
the religious and literary figures we find Shakespeare and I think Shakespeare
in this train of figures represents the literary that is also the dramatic.
So in our tradition,
Shakespeare is the literary name above all others.
It's important for Salinger that Shakespeare was a dramatist.
It's important for this novel that Shakespeare was a dramatist,
not just because Zoe wants Frannie to inhabit acting fully as her desire and as
her religious practice as opposed to saying the Jesus prayer
acting has a deeper relation to the novel and here's where we get back to that
question of the enclosed spaces and the lack of movement.
If you think about this novel,
it has the structures of drama,
it takes place in small rooms.
You can almost,
if you begin to think about it,
you can almost see the set changes
in the diner
on the train station.
That's about the most open place on the train platform.
That's about the most open place we see in the diner.
In the apartment.
All you do in the apartment is moved from one room to another.
These are dramatic spaces.
Moreover the bathroom completely a dramatic space.
It even has a curtain hiding Zoe from his mother.
Yeah.
Acting becomes a religious
practice for much more than Franny,
not just for Franny and for Zoe Cause Zoe's enactor too.
It's a religious practice for the novel itself.
Yeah.
And that I would suggest to you is where we can begin to bring some of those
obvious things,
the prevalence of dialogue,
those enclosed spaces,
the tone,
the exaggerated tone,
the somewhat histrionic quality,
the combativeness of that conversation.
It's sheer style.
These are great talkers.
Yeah.
But I would suggest to you Salinger is trying to balance something very
carefully that relates back to this question of doctrine versus syncretism in
the religious sphere of the novel,
in the religious thematic material of the novel.
And for this,
I'd like to look at the very end of the novel.
Zooey finally suggests that it's attention to the audience that makes an actor
really
a special actor or religious actor.
And he points back to advice that buddy gave him.
Yeah.
About,
sorry about that.
Seymour had given him about performing on a radio show.
So they were all radio show.
We as kids.
Yeah.
And one day Zoe had not wanted to shine his shoes and says,
this is on page 200.
Um,
that the announcer was a moron.
The studio audience.
We're all more on.
The sponsors were more ons and I just damn well wasn't going to shine my shoes
for them.
I told Seymour,
I said they couldn't see them anyway where we sat,
he said to shine them anyway.
He said to shine them for the fat lady.
Now why the Fat Lady?
It's this mythical,
incredibly humanly embodied and whenever you see a fat lady in a novel,
one of the first things you want to ask is why is that person need to be
excessively embodied?
That's what fatness is.
In a novel like this,
it's excessive embodiment.
The human.
That's what this woman represents.
The human connect to the human audience,
respect the human audience,
act for them to them.
Don't act as if they're just some,
a bunch of Philistines out there who can appreciate your art.
Yeah,
and then he says to Franny,
I'll tell you a terrible secret.
Are you listening to me?
There isn't anyone out there who isn't Seymour's fat lady.
That includes your professor,
Tupper buddy and all his goddamn cousins by the dozens.
There isn't anyone anywhere who isn't Seymour's fat lady.
Don't you know that?
Don't you know that God damn secret yet and don't you know.
Listen to me now.
Don't you know who the Fat Lady really is?
A buddy,
a buddy.
It's Christ himself,
Christ himself.
Buddy,
this seems like a completely Christian answer to Zoe's problem and we're back on
the horns of that dilemma.
Is this a syncretic religious vision or is it a Christian one?
But look what follows.
This is not the last word
for joy.
Apparently it was all Frannie could do to hold the phone even with both hands
for a foolish half minute or so.
There was no other words,
no further speech then I can't talk anymore buddy.
The sound of a phone being replaced on its catch followed Frannie took in her
breasts slightly,
but continued to hold the phone to her ear,
a dial tone of course.
Follow the formal break in the connection.
She appeared to find it extraordinarily beautiful to listen to rather as if it
were the best possible substitute for the primordial silence itself.
The dial tone is that state of awareness of the divine that buddy speaks of when
he says when he speaks of being with God before God said,
let there be light Zoe's voice breaking that dial tone in the beginning in his
phone call.
And then the resumption of it afterwards,
that dial tone in cases,
Zoe's voice.
So that what Zoe says to her is one of the rays of light of God's creation.
One of those things like Shakespeare that is part of the whole created world.
But what Frannie can tune into after hearing his voice is that very essential
divine sound,
meaningless sound.
Yeah.
And so this is how sound your balances the syncretic,
these sort of empty mysticism of Seymour and buddy with the embodied doc trinal
specific insistence that we see from Zoe from the insistence on humans
specificity,
the fat lady,
the very material human fleshly person
Salinger's own novel performs in this way.
And that's how you would,
that's how you would want to think about moments like,
um,
on the bottom of one 80.
Yeah.
This is describing the bedroom,
uh,
of Seymour and buddy as Zoe walks in
a stranger with a flair for cocktail party.
Descriptive prose might've commented that the room at a quick glance looked as
if it had once been tenanted by two struggling 12 year old lawyers or
researches.
It's um,
and then if you flip back to,
um,
let's see,
one 72,
okay,
describing Zoe's sweaty shirt,
his shirt was in the familiar phrase,
wringing wet.
And there are lots of moments like this self conscious moments of style.
So in the familiar phrase,
wringing wet,
he's saying,
I'm about to use a cliche.
Here it is.
There it is.
He says,
someone with a flair for cocktail party conversation.
A witticism would say this,
he gives it to us,
but he frames it as an affectation of style.
So what Salinger I think shows us is that affectation without something like
love
is just affectation.
And that's what lane represents.
That's the affectation of literature without any human connection.
That's why when he talks on and on,
it's as if Franny isn't even there listening to him.
He's been going on a quarter hour and he's just hitting his stride.
Franny,
Zoe,
buddy,
Bessie,
they all tried to speak directly to
each other.
The family language is what makes them very human.
They embody this very specific family language.
And so I would argue to you that sound,
you're imagines literature as a performance of this kind of performance of a
language of family love that is nevertheless also an aesthetic language.
And I think actually probably the best image of that is in Seymour's diary.
When Zoe sits down to make that phone call,
he opens up Seymour's diary and he sees Seymour's account of his birthday
celebration where the family had put on a Vaudeville show right in their living
room.
Remember,
his parents are Vaudevillians.
Yeah.
And that description,
uh,
which I won't read just because we're running out of time,
it's on 180180180 two.
You can look at it yourself.
It's brimming with pleasure and love.
This is why body really can't insist that Zoe is wrong about this being a
religious novel because being a religious novel and being a love story are
finally for Salinger the same thing.
It's the performance of human connection.
That's the phone line.
That's conversation,
that's letters.
The performance of family conversation is like acting.
And that is why Zoe impersonates buddy,
he's acting,
but Frannie can hear the specific voice.
And this is when you know that Franny is not just a sort of empty air head.
She may be mistaken about who she's praying,
two in the Jesus prayer,
but she damn well knows the Tambour of her brother's voice and his particularity
of speech.
And so when he tries to imitate buddy,
she finds him out very quickly.
And this is when you know that Franny really does benefit from Seymour and
buddy's religious education in the same way that Zoey has.
And so if we step back for a minute now from my reading,
there are a couple of things I want to say.
First of all,
I hope you can see just as using that as a model,
how I went from big claims about the novel into specificity to support those
claims.
That's the structure of any good literary argument.
The attention moves from the very small to the large and back again,
there's a kind of rhythm to that that folds in those obvious parts of the novel
to a more thematic sets.
A set of concerns in this case about the religious,
um,
philosophy of this novel.
So as you think about writing papers,
go through that two step process of thinking about the large picture of what a
novel is doing as a piece of literary art and then thinking about a focused set
of concerns and in the final development of your paper,
making sure that those two can relate to one another.
The second thing I want to say is less about paper writing and more about the
trajectory of this course in what we're seeing in common between these novels.
So you can read this very closely to on the road if dean cared for nothing,
but for everything in principle,
you could say conversely that Salinger cares for everything in particular and in
principle nothingness.
It's nothingness that is the mystical state rather than everythingness.
And it's interesting to think about whether those two are really opposites.
I think these novels imagined them to be opposites,
but it's something for you to think about about whether they really are.
Okay.
So Zoe's specificity is the specificity of doctrine,
but it's also the specificity and more importantly,
the specificity of person.
Okay.
So that's that.
That's the everything that he cares about person,
I will stop there.
And,
um,
please bring both on the road and Franny and Zooey to section this week.
And by the way,
one last thing,
if you've been sketchy about your section attendance,
I suggest that you try to pull up your socks and go,
um,
we will be talking about papers in the section.
It will be helpful to you and it will also give you a chance to talk about these
books.
So please do go.